the league sets aside a special day for
only a handful of players in the history
of major league baseball today we all
celebrate roberto clemente day fans
please join us in welcoming chase boykin
a young white sox fan who last weekend
captured the hearts of baseball fans
everywhere with his impression in the
stands of white sox pitcher craig
kimbrell as he announces the start of
tonight's game
chicago let's play ball
that's dallas kykel it's been a rough go
since the all-star break one in six with
an era of seven and a half shohei will
be the next hitter struck him out a
change up indoors and two gone
left on left change up it was a beauty
right in under the hands of ohtani two
out walk and walsh will come up 3-1
pitch ground ball right side cesar
hernandez deep in the shift will make
the play about 10 feet into the outfield
and kykel works around a two-out walk
25-year-old rookie right-hander jansen
junk on the mount for the angels making
his second career big league starting
assignment two gone for jose abreu
here's the next delivery and he swings
it down and lifts it in the air to right
field it's hanging up and under making
the grab on that one is juan legaris and
it's a quick clean inning for junk now
the ancients put their lead off hitter
aboard to start the second kurt suzuki
that will be helpful it's garcia and
hernandez and it's a double play taylor
made that's exactly what dallas kykel
does when he's at his best and throws
ground balls and double play balls
brandon marsh kyker brings the 1-2 home
and it's a wave and a miss on a sinker
down
one two three through the angels goes
dallas kykel four up four down for the
rookie right-hander and now it's a loy
jimenez two and two and a swing and a
miss and the first strike out of the
night for junk three balls and two
strikes on gavin sheets now payoff pitch
and that one there it's chased and
missed a fastball 93 throws it by him
struck him out back-to-back strikeouts
to wrap up the inning one gun here in
the top of the third for luis redheapho
there's a 2-0 from kykel and there's the
first hit of the ball game renjifo is a
board with one out first and second with
one gone
and ohtani sends it on the ground to
abreu he'll get the one out at first
base
second and third now with two away
counseling goes after the first pitch
bounces the ball to third fielded by
moncada and the throw is in time says
the umpire over there chris conroy the
stride
and always say safe he's definitely safe
for sure should the angels challenge
this and they are they're going to take
another look at it on the field it looks
like this one's going to come back and
it's going to mean a run for the halos
yes coming back calls overturned and
that means the angels have taken a
one-nothing lead seven in a row retired
by junk one gone for the former angel
brian goodwin
lying softly to fletch who hadn't played
perfectly two out now and cesar
hernandez will hit
ground ball into right and the sox had
their first hit
knight batter
snaps an o for eight to start the game
against chance and junk robert will be
the next batter
and a lazy fly ball out to right
as hot as he is junk has taken care of
him twice hurts suzuki to hit her now
kurt suzuki with the drive to left field
sheets is back on it and it's off the
top of the wall
[Applause]
kurtz into second having just missed a
solo homer first and third now with one
gun here's a pitch swing a miss
he struck him out and that is out number
two it'll bring up renjifo
who wants it's going to be mankata
and he got a good stretch by brayu
and the white sox get out of the inning
on some solid defense from jawan mankata
and jose of brave and here is joan
leading off and the 3-1
[Applause]
tie ball game in the fourth these home
runs are leaving with speed
that ball was crushed laying a fastball
on the inside corner to a left-hander
like monkata on base streak now 25 games
yeah kykel just walked the bases loaded
here in the fifth and jack mayfield will
be the next batter
on the ground at third moncada to the
bag he loads up the throw and pito's got
the scoop everybody held their breath
for a second that ball was headed toward
the turf
another double play for the white sox
and kykel's out of the inning runners at
the corners now hernandez will be the
next battery
walsh is going to come home and sheets
is laid out and tagged out easily by a
good few steps and it's still a 1-1 ball
game and that one right there it is
chased and missed he struck him out and
that is how the inning will end
and the angels have a one out base
runner and the batter now will be juan
legaris
juan lagarde shoots the base hitting the
right and the halos have something
cooking here with one gun in the sixth
and going first to third on that one
will be marsh angels have something
brewing again against kykel now runners
at the corners one out and ring heapho
will be the next batter renjifo swinging
away sends a fly ball out to right for
goodwin
that's going to be enough to tag up
brandon marsh the throw to the plates
off line and the angels go back out in
front by a run jose abreu he's been
quiet not only tonight but in the series
down the line fair ball of brayu
this is a double waiting to happen jose
throttles down into a one out two base
hit and the sox are trying to come right
on back so now an rbi opportunity for
yasmani grandah who's one for seven in
the series
yeah his right side past the dive of
walsh
here comes jose
and the game's tied
that was fast what a year grand all has
had he's been at his best since he came
off the injured list how about 55 hits
and now 57 knocked in that also
stretches grondol's career best on base
streak to 30 straight games here's
michael kopeck dallas keiko will get a
no decision tonight and he was good six
innings two runs
tawny hasn't hit one out of the infield
yet tonight in fact hasn't yet in the
series number three on the ground and
past kopeck and that actually is going
to benefit the white sox
as garcia was right near the bag at
second and made the play bill gosling
will be the next batter
on a slider first time gosselin's been
retired tonight see that that's just
absolutely unfair because when you lay
off
you believe that you have just saved
yourself the ignominy of a swinging
strikeout on a slider the o2
on the fastball
nice work michael kopeck against ohtani
gosselin and walsh kopeck's able to
record the second out of the unit here's
brandon marsh with two out the base is
empty
fastball hit out to center field robert
watches it fly brandon marsh straightens
out a 101 mile an hour fastball to give
the halos a three to two lead boy a
great at that got even better with that
swing brandon marsh sea check has given
up back-to-back hits they have runners
at first and second now tying a run at
second base and abreu their top rbi man
the next batter
got him swinging man i don't think you
could place a fastball any better than
that and grand all the catcher and
cleanup batter will be the next hitter
he struck him out a sinker gets him and
the inning is over angels would love to
wrap up the clemente day celebrations
with a win on the road
they've got their best bullet out of the
bullpen to try to do it rysel iglesias
here in the last of the ninth he'll face
alloy jimenez gavin sheets and leori
garcia
[Applause]
drive to left and this is off the wall
eloy jimenez into second base that's the
tying run
and a lead off double that didn't take
long and billy hamilton will come out
pitch run with gavin sheets at the plate
1-2 delivery got him chased that change
up and missed it struck him out now that
time run is at third base with only one
god runners at the corners here so here
is brian goodwin who's had some big home
runs for the white sox this year
got him swinging
elevated heater did the trick so the
second out in the inning they've each
come on strikeouts cesar hernandez has
had some previous success against ryzel
iglesias in the air the other way
gosselin is under it to retire the side
and end the game the halos hang on and
the angels are three to two winners in
chicago tonight
you